hey ich bin mag ich würd ich habe mir
für das heutige video was bestellt ihr
kennt es ja manchmal ruhig wie
irgendwelche kuriosen dinge aus dem
internet für videos und das habe ich
mich für heute ihr seht es ist storm
bett nichts geredet als zone ungefähr so
die chinesische anwälte sagen wir haben
kein geld für wird man jetzt hin
es soll angeblich an wänden fahren
können also ist es echt krass also ein
spielzeugauto das anwenden von jetzt 3 6
dicht
wir sehen hier den liefern kann
wir haben ein auto eine fernbedienung
und eine bedienungsanleitung also hier
wir gucken uns mal an was diese
vermischung für funktion also man kann
nach vorne nach hinten fahren die
weitere funktion light touch climbing
mode also das ding danke dass du gerade
ins netz
kleibrink mit dem man angeblich an der
wand fahren kann
neben dem kann man klettern ich habe die
vermutung weil das funktioniert so das
wird irgendwie durch diesen durch dieses
teil der verdächtigt wird durch dieses
teil hier unten angezogen oder was
angesaugt angesagt
es wird angesagt an die wand und ich
mach das jetzt einfach mal an bis macht
einfach gar kein geld wirklich mal dass
hier an wo das rauchen bogen hatte war
jetzt mit ina qualität aber was war das
habe ich mir einfach bei amazon bestellt
jetzt gesehen wie schnell das rad war
das einfach ein batmobil 606 fest der
farben boden lassen nicht mal als er das
doch keine art lassen den fahrer wenn es
ist diese person war staubsauger hat der
bank vontobel was ist mit dem auto los
also mainz hat 13 euro inklusive versand
dieser zeit überlegen wenn ich hier nach
vorne drücken einer fordert wert was für
die bewegung hätten ein paar alte
bewegung und baidu lenken
ich bin nur einen seite
klar ist klappt das fast immer etwas los
ist
[Musik]
also bisher auch ebenfalls eine gute
investition aber erstmal wirklich so ich
mache draufmachen hinkriegt dass
irgendwie auch so ein teppich ein
bisschen mehr traktion ja das
funktioniert auf jeden fall war
ich setze ist jetzt mal an die wand mit
ihnen an der wand funktionen teilen und
herren mag das auto dran platziert und
wird jetzt im browser machen der mit dem
würde ich sagen die wand an sorgt der
wahrheit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
diesen modus an haben damit noch
einfahren können unser retter und vater
des gedanken an die band ist instant
runter so nützlich
[Musik]
junge war ein herunterfahren
aber hier kann sie direkt an die das
auch umgehen
und er ist nie so direkt an der wand
[Musik]
langlauf
ich war viel geld ausgegeben hat er was
er hektar wiese zur kenntnis genommen
eigentlich woran es lag dass es nicht
geklappt hat
jetzt muss war kein druck auf wer das
schon jetzt schon das schon mal das
schon wird das heißt schon mit
wer will kann von heute keine bieter es
viele wissen gar nicht auto fahren das
ist alles meine damen und herren ich
packe das auto an die warten und wir
sehen und fand viele spieler viele im
vorfeld
ich war wirklich
nein ob irgendwas verweisen wir dieses
englische arbeiten
[Applaus]
zwar haben wir auch im basketball fahren
bei 20.000 leisten
nein er hat wirklich alles da würde ich
hier hatte man gleich bei diesem video
das gar nicht mit anfragen wo du einmal
machen mal anprobiert an die wand zu
bewerten als roboter anschrift an die
wand schlägt sich andrea kommt ihr fazit
ich will auf jeden fall sagen brauchen
das paket ist das auch zum start und
ziel an der macht